TEAM MENTALLY AND EMOTIONALLY
RECOVER AFTER BEING UP SO BIG
AND LOSING IN THIS FASHION?
>> Marv: LET'S CHECK IN WITH
JARED GREENBERG.
JARED?
>> Jared: A PERFORMANCE FOR THE
AGES TONIGHT BY KEVIN DURANT.
NICE TO SEE YOU AGAIN, KEVIN.
YOU SAID THAT THE OTHER DAY YOU
WERE READY TO ADAPT TO ANY
SITUATION.
HOW MUCH OF THAT INCLUDED
PREPARING FOR PLAYING EVERY
MINUTE OF TONIGHT'S GAME?
>> I MEAN, I WASN'T PLANNING ON
PLAYING EVERY MINUTE BUT AS THE
GAME STARTED TO FLOW, WE GOT
DOWN.
I TOLD COACH UNDER IF HE NEEDED
ME TO TAKE OUT A COUPLE, IT WAS
COOL BUT I FEEL GOOD AND HE LET
ME RIDE IT OUT.
JEFF GREEN WAS INCREDIBLE
TONIGHT.
JAMES COMING OUT HERE AND
THUGGING IT OUT FOR US.
CREATING TO BE ANOTHER BALL
HANDLER FOR US.
THE SECOND HALF WE PLAYED
EXTREMELY HARD.
>> Jared: WHAT I WANTED TO ASK
YOU ABOUT NEXT.
YOU WERE MEGAIN THE SECOND HALF.
BUT WHAT WAS THIS HALFTIME
SPEECH LIKE FROM COACH NASH THAT
FLIPPED THE SWITCH FOR YOU GUYS?
>> CONTINUE PLAYING DEFENSE
BECAUSE OUR SHOTS WEREN'T
FALLING.
WE WERE RUSHING A LOT ON OFFENSE
TOO.
WE WERE TRYING TO GET EVERYTHING
BACK SO FAST BEING DOWN 10, 12
POINTS.
I THINK WE SETTLED IN AND MADE
GOOD SHOTS AND GUYS CAME IN AND
KNOCKED DOWN SOME SHOTS IN THAT
THIRD.
BLAKE, JEFF, LANDRY.
WE PUT OURSELVES IN A GOOD
POSITION WHEN WE MOVE THE BALL
THAT FAST.
>> Jared: A HIGH NOTE THERE,
KEVIN.
THAT'S IT.
>> I APPRECIATE IT.
>> Jared: MARV?
>> Marv: THANK YOU, JARED.
DURANT 49 POINTS AND 17 REBOUNDS
AND 10 ASSISTS.
HE TALKED ABOUT JEFF GREEN'S
PERFORMANCE.
A PLAYOFF CAREER HIGH FOR JEFF
GREEN, 26 POINTS.
HE HIT 7 OF 8 FROM THREE-POINT
RANGE AND THE NETS END UP
SHOOTING 49% FROM THE FIELD.
JAMES HARDEN WENT 46 MINUTES,
JUST 1 FOR 10 FROM THE FIELD BUT
HE HUNG IN THERE WITH THAT
STRAINED HAMSTRING AND HAD